marc lavergne bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
peut-être votre réaction à cette
dernière information les forces du tigre
et donc ont revendiqué les tirs de
roquettes sur deux aéroports et elles
menacent maintenant de s'en prendre à
l'erythrée ces dernières informations
sont inquiétantes
oui bien entendu parce que ça ne va pas
dans la voie de l'apaisement et c'est
une guerre fratricide qui ne fera que
des vastres de tous les côtés le fait
que les tigres et 1 et bombarder les
aéroports de godard et de bahar dar
c'est quelque chose de très logique
puisque c'est de là que partent les
avions qui bombardent mais quelle est la
capitale du tigre et donc ils ont les
moyens techniques je dirais et dont
l'armement les roquettes qui leur
permettent de tirer à 500 km de là enfin
pour le cas de bardach donc c'est
effectivement un combat fratricide et
suicidaire je dirais qui ne fait que des
adaptations dans la population civile de
deux côtés et qui ne règle pas les
problèmes de fond qui sont à l'origine
de cette guerre justement quelle est la
genèse du conflit entre les deux camps
qui s'accusent mutuellement de massacre
de la population
moi c'est un problème au départ entre le
gouvernement central qui cherche à
réaffirmer son autorité sur l'ensemble
des provinces éthiopienne et l'ethiopie
est un état fédéral multi ethnique qui
est en train de partir en lambeaux
d'une certaine manière donc premier
ministre habib ahmed a essayé lui mais
assez maladroitement finalement de
conserver l'unité du pays
il a profité de la crise de la copie de
19 pour repousser les élections qui
devaient permettre à toutes les régions
de s'exprimer finalement et d'avoir voix
au chapitre au niveau du moment son
talent lui est un centralisateur et les
gens du tigre et qui se sentent
dépossédés du pouvoir depuis son arrivée
et bien avait déjà prévu de se renforcer
sur leurs bases dans la région du tigré
et d'affirmer leur demande
d'indépendance mais en réalité c'est une
demande surtout d'être
reconnu et d'avoir vos chats titre au
niveau central qu'est ce qu'ils ont
dirigé eux mêmes l'ethiopie faut pas
l'oublier pendant 30 ans alors qu'est ce
qu'on sait en tout cas de la situation
actuelle dans la région dans cette
région du tigré
est-ce que les crimes de guerre sont
avérées est-ce qu'on a une idée du
nombre de morts à l'heure où on se parle
on n'a pas d'idée du nombre de morts
dans l'ensemble mais on a effectivement
des échos des témoignages qui
parviennent de gens qui passent la
frontière vers le soudan et qui parle de
massacres 1 il ya des choses qui sont
tout à fait avéré comme un mayara où il
ya eu à peine quelques dizaines
peut-être centaines de civils de paysans
amara qui ont été massacrées qui étaient
là qui habitait au tigré qui faisait
leur vie dans cette région et qui
auraient été massacrés par les forces
éventuellement de 2-1
mais ce qui est dangereux aussi dans
cette affaire c'est que le gouvernement
central a mobilisé des milices de toutes
les régions avoisinantes qui ont des
raisons de détester si vous voulez les
tigres est un donc il ya des oromos il
ya des amarats qui eux sont beaucoup
moins contrôlé sont pas une armée
régulière et peuvent se livre à des
massacres à des vengeances
il ya beaucoup d'émotions dans tout ça
elle beaucoup d'hommes de ressentiment
ressel respectifs et je pense que ce
qu'on devrait attendre du pouvoir
central
c'est très rapidement de calmer le jeu
en proposant une réunion des tables
rondes et des discussions sur ce que
veulent les vins les autres parce que
effectivement l'offensive militaire elle
a été lancée par le premier ministre un
ses habits ahmad sarr dirigeants
appréciés de la communauté
internationale cette même communauté qui
s'alarment aujourd'hui oui mais la
communauté internationale ne connaît
rien à la dimension proprement
éthiopienne dans cette corne de
l'afrique
ils ont surtout vu caviar med était
quelqu un homme neuf à 1 finalement un
technocrate disons un bon c'était lui
qui dirigeait les services de sécurité
donc il a quand même une connaissance
intime des problèmes de cette fédération
mais il a réglé la situation de guerre
qui était une liliane ip avec l'erythrée
ils à régler d'autres conflits avec les
pays voisins mais il sait moins occupés
finalement des problèmes internes en
pensant que construisant ce grand
barrage sur le nil bleu qui a provoqué
des problèmes avec l'egypte et le soudan
ils allaient aspirer tout les éthiopiens
vers le haut vers la mondialisation vers
le développement économique mais n'a pas
vraiment réussi là dessus et du coup les
gens sont une situation de misère qui
est provoquée en plus par les criquets
par les inondations
et puis maintenant il ya cette guerre
qui est quatre là surtout ce tapis de
frustration merci beaucoup marc lavergne
pour votre éclairage
elle rappelle que vous êtes directeur du
rheu de du directeur de recherche pardon
au cnrs et spécialiste de la corne de
l'afrique